die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend für die sportlichen
Höhepunkt ist Katja wieder mit mir im
Studio ja schön guten Abend dann blicken
wir gemeinsam auf die Themen des
Tages Zankapfel Bürgergeld die Ampel
ringt um einen Sparhaushalt die FDP
fordert die Erhöhung der Sozialleistung
zum Jahreswechsel zu
streichen Taktik und Todesangst Israel
rückt mit B aufanunis im Süden des
Gazastreifens vor eine Katastrophe für
die
Zivilbevölkerung und die Jugend macht's
vor die U17 Weltmeister sind zurück und
dürfen sich im Frankfurter Römer ins
Goldene Buch der Stadt
[Musik]
eintragen sparen bedeutet immer auch
Nein zu sagen die ampelregierung ist in
der Haushaltskrise noch auf der Suche
nach dem richtigen nein die FDP sagt
NEIN zu noch mehr Schulden kann sich
Einsparungen etwa beim Bürgergeld
vorstellen genau dazu sagen Grüne und
SPD nein sie wollen die geplante
Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes beibehalten um
wie viel Geld es geht und wie es
berechnet wird dazu Julia
Schröter in Deutschland beziehen 5,5
Millionen Menschen Bürgergeld der Satz
für eine alleinstehende Person etwa
beträgt aktuell 502 € im Monat im
kommenden Jahr soll der Satz steigen auf
563 €. die bürgergeldsätze sollen ab
Januar im Schnitt um 12 % steigen den
Bund kostet die Erhöhung rund 3,4
Milliarden Euro die bürgergeldsätze
berechnen sich aus der jährlichen Lohn
und preisentwicklung in einem
komplizierten mehrstufigen Verfahren
haben die Experten wegen der hohen
Inflation für
2024 eine Erhöhung von eben 12%
ermittelt dass die Inflation nun zum
Ende des Jahres überraschend deutlich
gesunken ist spielt für die aktuelle
Berechnung keine Rolle wenn die niedrige
Inflation sich aber fortsetzt werden
künftige Anpassungen beim Bürgergeld
entsprechend niedriger
ausfallen ja ob
Einsparpotenziale oder doch neue
Schulden die Koalitionsspitzen räumen
dem Haushalt 24 oberste Priorität ein
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck kzelte seine
Reise zum Weltklimagipfel und dem
Treffen vom Finanzminister Vizekanzler
und Kanzler gestern soll schnell ein
weiteres folgen über verhärtete
ampelfronten gerade beim Bürgergeld
berichtet Daniel
ponen diese selbstbedienungsmetzgerei
ist Folge des Fachkräftemangels der
droht in den nächsten Jahren noch
erheblich zu wachsen nicht nur deshalb
stellt die FDP jetzt im Zuge der
Haushaltsdebatte die geplante Erhöhung
des Bürgergelds in Frage sondern auch
weil diejenigen die arbeiten vielach
kein vergleichbares Lohnplus erhalten
das Lohnabstandsgebot ist gerade im
niedrig Lohnsektor nicht mehr
gewährleistet und wir müssen alles dafür
tun und es muss ganz nach wie vor gelten
wer arbeitet muss mehr haben als jemand
der nicht arbeitet beide
Koalitionspartner wollen an der Erhöhung
festhalten Arbeits- und Sozialminister
huberto Seil nennt die Kritik an der
Erhöhung moralisch
unverantwortlich es ist kein Beitrag zu
gesellschaftlichem Frieden wenn man
jetzt Gruppen in der Gesellschaft
gegeneinander ausspielt das ist keine
Lösung des Problems sondern wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass soziale Sicherheit in
Deutschland da ist für die Menschen die
auf den Staat angewiesen sind und das
Arbeit sich lohnen genau daran aber
Kranke ist derzeit heißt es auch aus der
Union die Erhöhung des Bürgergelds um
12% lehnt auch sie ab wegen der hohen
Kosten und ebenfalls mit Verweis auf
zumeist geringere Zuwächse bei
Arbeitnehmern ganz generell brauche es
eine Neujustierung des Bürgergelds so
der
Generalsekretär allein der Begriff
Bürgergeld suggeriert dass es allen
zusteht ist totaler Quatsch das müssen
diejenigen bekommen die wirklich
hilfebedürftig sind und alle anderen die
Arbeiten können die müssen auch einer
Arbeit nachgehen das ist so in einem
Sozialstaat und das wird auch den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt stärken
das Bürgergeld nur ein Streitpunkt beim
Haushalt über den sich die Ampel rasch
einig werden
muss die Debatte im Blick hat Diana
Zimmermann in Berlin Diana vor allem die
FDP sieht ein spparpotential beim
Bürgergeld wie realistisch wäre das ich
halte das für nicht sehr realistisch das
liegt an mehreren Punkten erstens
scheint es technisch tatsächlich
schwierig zu sein die ganze Umstellung
jetzt noch zurückzunehmen dreieinhalb
Wochen vor Jahresende zweitens ist es
gesetzlich schwierig denn die Anhebung
des Bürgergeldes wurde mit den Stimmen
der Union übrigens in Bundestag und
Bundesrat beschlossen und müsste da auch
wieder durchgehen um zurückgenommen zu
werden vor allen Dingen aber ist es
politisch eine etwas schwierige
Entscheidung vor allen Dingen für den
Kanzler SPD und Grüne möchten nicht dass
ausgerechnet bei den Ärmsten in der
Gesellschaft gespart wird sie haben sich
heute sehr vement dagegen ausgesprochen
bei der bürgergeldanhebung zu sparen und
der Kanzler hat am Ende der Woche einen
SPD Parteitag vor sich dann möchte er
sicherlich mit dieser Entscheidung nicht
auflaufen also insgesamt eine ziemlich
verfahrende Situation wie geht's denn
nun
weiter ja bis Mittwoch ist Zeit da ist
Kabinettssitzung und wenn der Haushalt
24 noch dieses Jahr verabschiedet werden
soll dann müssten sich die ampelspitzen
bis dahin geeinigt haben die Zeit läuft
und
es ist so dass der Wirtschaftsminister
seine Reise ja schon abgesagt hat
tatsächlich verschärfen sich die
Konflikte eher hat man den Eindruck der
Finanzminister vor allen Dingen hat
heute noch einmal bekräftigt
Schuldenbremse und die Verhinderung von
Steuererhöhung sind seine Kernanliegen
er hat sogar indirekt damit gedroht aus
der Ampel auszusteigen wenn diese roten
Linien wie er es nannte überschritten
würden wenn er dabei bleibt muss das
alles zusammengespart werden das erfdert
sehr viel viel Rechnerei und verhandeln
und der Kanzler hat deswegen auch seine
morgen nach Bayern geplante Reise zwar
nicht abgesagt aber doch verkürzt er
kommt früher zurück als geplant
fortsetzung folgt vielen Dank für die
Einordnung Derner Zimmermann nach Berlin
in den Nahen Osten israel hat den
Einsatz seiner Bodentruppen auf den
gesamten Gazastreifen ausgeweitet
konzentrrierten sich die Angriffe der
israelischen Armee bislang vor allem auf
den Norden von Gaza geht sie jetzt auch
im Süden verstärkt gegen die
Terrororganisation Hamas vor inzwischen
sollen die Soldaten bis zur Stadt han
Junis vorgerückt sein dorthin waren
viele Palästinenser aus dem Norden
geflüchtet und sie sollen sich jetzt
noch weiter im Süden in Raffa in
Sicherheit bringen sagt Israel luten
leinos
dazu der Einsatz israelischer
Bodentruppen auch im Süden des
Gazastreifens ist eine neue Etappe in
diesem Krieg der Auftrag für die
Soldaten sie sollen die Führung der
Hamas aufspüren und ihre militärischen
Fähigkeiten
zerstören wir werden die Hammers
ausfindig machen wo immer sie sich
versteckt im Norden und im Süden ihre
Raketenwerfer Waffendepots
kommandoozentralen ihre unterirdische
Infrastruktur und mögliche Verstecke in
denen unsere Geiseln festgehalten
werden Schwerpunkt der israelischen
Angriffe
heuteunis zweitgrößte Stadt des
gaserastreifens ist in der Nacht wieder
schwer bombardiert worden mit
sogenannten evakuierungskarten im
Internet warnt Israels Armee vor
Angriffen die Bevölkerung wird darin
aufgefordert große Teile von hananjunes
zu verlassen doch Strom und Funknetz
fallen häufig aus Warnungen kommen nicht
an besser funktionieren die von der
Armee abgeworfenen
Flugblätter wir haben die Warnung
gesehen dass wir gehen sollen aber wo
sollen wir hin wir bleiben lieber hier
in unserem Zelt
sie ist froh mit ihrer Familie inunis
wenigstens ein Zelt ergattert zu haben
in den letzten Wochen sind
hundertausende Menschen aus dem Norden
hierher geflüchtet und wissen jetzt
nicht
weiter es gibt Bombenangriffe es gibt
keinen sicheren Ort nicht mal die
Schulen selbst die Stadt Raffa im
äußersten Süden erlebte heute schwere
Luftangriffe im gaserstreifen scheint es
kaum noch einen sicheren Ort zu
geben eine ganz andere Sicht auf den
Nahostkonflikt als Deutschland hat der
Gast den Olaf Scholz heute im Kanzleramt
begrüßte Brasiliens Präsident Lula er
nennt Israels Angriff auf Gaza einen
Genozid auch Sanktionen gegen Russland
lehnt Lula ab trotzdem verbindet beide
Länder einiges Wirtschaft und Umwelt
stehen da ganz oben aus Berlin Frank
Buchwald der Mann aus dem Süden mag
gefröstelt haben am Morgen vor Schloss
belvu Brasiliens Präsident Lula zurück
in Berlin der Empfang ist herzlich
politisch aber liegt viel aufgestautes
Eis zwischen Brasilia und Europa ETW ein
Handelsabkommen das seit langem
blockiert
ist nach 23 Jahren Verhandlungen in
denen wir keine Vereinbarung zustande
bekommen haben wären wir wirklich
unvernünftig wenn wir unser
Handelsabkommen jetzt nicht endlich
abschließen
würden alle größeren deutschen
Unternehmen sind längst in saan Paulo
präsent fast jedes Auto kommt von VW das
Freihandelsabkommen aber seit
Jahrzehnten blockiert Europas Bauern
fürchteten die starke Konkurrenz aus dem
Süden brasilianische Bauern liefern
längst Soja nach China Umweltschützer
kämpfen gegen Holzeinschlag im Amazonas
Regenwald und Rinderzucht Klimaschutz
Topthema deshalb heute auch in Berlin im
Rahmen unserer neuen Partnerschaft
wollen wir mit gemeinsamen Projekten das
Ziel Null Entwaldung bis 2030 in
Brasilien unterstützen und wir werden
klimaneutrale Industrien aufbauen und in
die Klimaforschung investieren die
beiden haben dann noch einige
Absichtserklärungen unterzeichnet gegen
Hass im Netz für Kooperation in der
Landwirtschaft Energie und Bildung gute
Absichten höflicher Applaus Brasilien
aber geht längst seinen eigenen Weg und
Wunschpartner ist längst nicht mehr nur
Europa großes Entsetzen vor 3 Jahren als
ein Mann in trie mit seinem Auto fünf
Fußgänger tötete und viele schwer
verletzte der Bundesgerichtshof hat
jetzt die lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe
gegen den Amokfahrer wegen Rechtsfehlern
aufgehoben das Trierer Landgericht muss
neu verhandeln das Gericht habe die
Schuldunfähigkeit des schizofrenen
Mannes zu pauschal beurteilt und müsse
auch berücksichtigen welchen Einfluss
Alkohol spielte dass der Mann die
Menschen umfuhr sei aber unstrittig so
der
BGH was ist mit sind 239 Menschen an
Bord des Fluges
mh370 passiert seit fast 10 Jahren
stellen sich die Angehörigen überwiegend
Chinesen die immer gleiche Frage am 8
März 2014 ist die Boeing der Malaysia
Airlines auf dem Weg von Koal Lumpur
nach Peking als sie plötzlich von den
Radarschirmen verschwindet die Maschine
wird nie gefunden nur einzelne
Wrackteile weit weg von der eigentlichen
Flugroute etwa vor der Insel La Reunion
in Peking klagen jetzt Familien von
vermissten auf Entschädigungen Elisabeth
Schmidt
berichtetong ist für seinen Sohn nach
Peking gekommen der war an Bord der
Boeing 777 und hat zwei Kinder
zurückgelassen um die sich jetzt der
71jährige kümmert all seine Ersparnisse
und seine Rente braucht er jetzt für
seine
Enkel wenn Sie fragen wo ist Papa dann
sage ich er ist in den USA um zu
studieren denn es gibt noch
Hoffnung hoffen in einem fast 10 Jahre
langem Albtraum wen und die anderen
Kläger fordern bis zu 10 Millionen EUR
Schadenersatz von Malaysia Airlines und
drei weiteren Firmen vor allem aber dass
die Suche nach mh370 wieder aufgenommen
wird das Gerichtsgebäude heute streng
kontrolliert und abgeriegelt uns wird
verboten davor zu drehen also wir werden
jetzt hier in eine interviewzone gebeten
die eigens für uns errichtet wurde damit
wir weg vom Gericht kommen mit anderen
Worten die Journalisten oder in dem Fall
nur wir sollen bitte weit weg vom
Geschehen warten Wut und Kritik in der
Öffentlichkeit unerwünscht doch auch
nach dem Prozess will wen seine
Geschichte
weitererzählen ob es nun 10 oder 20
Jahre dauert der Schmerz hört nicht auf
selbst wenn Sie uns eine Kompensation
zahlen einen Monat haben die Beklagten
nun Zeit auf die Forderungen
einzugehen dass sein Albtraum endlich
endet jetzt nach Indonesien wo einer der
etwa 120 aktiven Vulkane die Menschen in
Atem hält der marapi zu deutschfeuerberg
ist wieder ausgebrochen und riss
mindestens
Bergsteiger in den Tod 52 konnten
gerettet werden nach Vermissten wird
noch gesucht die Bergsteiger hätten sich
nach Behördenangaben nicht dem Gipfel
nähern dürfen und haben dies offenbar
missachtet
in Süddeutschland ging auf den Schienen
am Wochenende fast gar nichts mehr kaum
schneids mal fährt keine Bahn mag so
mancher gedacht haben aber hat das
Krisenmanagement tatsächlich versagt es
war schon sehr sehr viel Schnee der da
runter kam wie wintertauglich ist die
Bahn dazu Cordelia
Strauß so viel Neuschnee in so kurzer
Zeit das hatte es in München seit Jahren
nicht gegeben vier Tage nach dem
Wintereinbruch bereiten die Schneemassen
weiter Probleme viele Bahnen fahren
nicht in München betrifft das den nah
und den Fernverkehr weichen müssen vom
Schnee befreit werden allein in und um
die Landeshauptstadt gab es nach
Auskunft der Bahn 80 Schäden an
Oberleitungen und da der Schnee am
Wochenende fiel war zunächst ein
Bereitschaftsdienst im Einsatz ich
wüsste nicht was ich auf ein Ereignis
sich einmal im Jahr 100 ergibt noch
anders vorbereiten kann wie jetzt wir
haben eine funktionierende Mannschaft
die die Entstörung Drau vorantreibt die
die Krisenstäbe intern koordiniert und
ich glaube wir haben auch Kunden die
Verständnis haben für das was gerade
passiert eben weil es etwas ganz
Außergewöhnliches ist trotz aller
Bemühungen die Bahn sei wenig
wintertauglich kritisiert der
Fahrgastverband probahn in der
Vergangenheit sei zu viel gespart worden
in den letzten Jahrzehnten hat die Bahn
es verpasst ausreichend Personal und
räummöglichkeiten für einen solchen
Extremfall bereit zu halten und auch
Abstellgleise sind zurückgebaut worden
und deswegen ist es schwierig einfach
mal einen Zug irgendwo abzustellen wenn
der nicht mehr fahren kann in München
bleibt der Bahnverkehr heute stark
eingeschränkt morgen könnte gefrierender
Regen weitere Probleme bereiten die Bahn
bittet Reisende nicht notwendige Fahrten
auf Mittwoch und später zu verschieben
und das Wetter bleibt ungemütlich mit
Schnee und Glätte der Flughafen München
stellt morgen Vormittag seinen Betrieb
wegen Eisregens vorübergehend ein auch
am Frankfurter Flughafen waren die Räume
und enteisungsfahrzeuge im Dauereinsatz
Flüge wurden annulliert die stat- und
Landebahnen mussten geräumt werden im
Taunus da war der Verkehr stark
beeinträchtigt bei schwallbach gab es
mehrere Verletzte als sechs Fahrzeuge
miteinander
kollidierten miteinander statt
nebeneinander das Ehrenamt mache da den
Unterschied das sagte Bundespräsident
Stein
bei der Verleihung von Verdienstorden an
Zeh Frauen und neun Männer im Schloss
belvue betonte Steinmeier es sei wichtig
bessere Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen um
Ehrenamt zu ermöglichen dazu gehörten
familienfreundliche Bedingungen und der
Schutz derer die sich kommunalpolitisch
engagieren ja und gleich noch ein
offizieller Termin in Frankfurt mit den
fußballweltmeistern Katja ja zwei Tage
nach dem packenden Finale GEG Frankreich
nach dem großen Triumph dem Titelgewinn
in durften sich die U17 Fußballer heute
in Frankfurt ins Goldene Buch der Stadt
eintragen nach einem 16stundenfug von
Indonesien nach Deutschland wirkten die
U17 Helden erstaunlich frisch als sie am
Morgen im Frankfurter Römer empfangen
wurden dabei liegt ein Feiermarathon
hinter den Weltmeistern nach dem
Finalsieg gegen Frankreich mit eiskalt
ausgeführten mern wir geben niemals auf
so das Erfolgsrezept eine Einstellung
die man im deutschen Fußball zuletzt
häufig vermisst
hatungs haben sowohl bei der
Europameisterschaft als jetzt auch noch
mal in Indonesien bei der
Weltmeisterschaft das war so nicht zu
erwarten wir hatten es uns erhofft und
er arbeitet Trainer Christian Wück hat
eine extrem gute Mannschaft geformt egal
auf Platz einfach zusammen teampir kann
man gar nicht beschreiben das hat noch
niemand geschafft und deswegen klar das
ist was ganz besonderes und das wissen
wir auch und darauf sind wir stolz jetzt
gilt es diese goldene Generation auch
weiter zu
entwickeln
bei der Handball WM der Frauen in
Skandinavien geht's für die Deutschen
heute zum Abschluss der Gruppenphase
darum wichtige Punkte für die Hauptrunde
zuusammeln die Gegnerinnen sind aus
Polen und ebenfalls
ungeschlagen heitere Stimmung beim
Gruppenbild mit rotgedressten Fans
Spielerinnen des Landesligisten Rensburg
Deutschlands Nationalspielerinnen mit
Engelsgeduld Fotos können ja so
glücklich machen was ein Schlüsselmoment
wie der Siegtreffer gegen Japan in
letzter Sekunde des auftagtspiels doch
ausmachen kann auch Bundestrainer
gaugisch sei hier tiefen entspannt auch
wenn die ebenfalls zweimal siegreichen
Polinen überaus ernst genommen werden
der großgewachsene Mannschaft sehr sehr
stark aus dem Rückraum aggressiv in der
Deckung also es wird schon taffes Spiel
werden aber mit ganz klarem Ziel dass
wir die zwei Punkte auch da holen wollen
damit sie auch nach dem dritten Spiel
bestens gelaunt aus der Halle schreiten
können 20:30 Uhr ist anfiff in Herning
in Dänemark na denn vielen Dank Katja
sehr gern ja bei uns gerade Schnee und
Kälte das lässt den Igel aber kalt denn
der begibt sich in den Winterschlaf wird
also erst irgendwann im März von seiner
Auszeichnung erfahren die deutsche
wildtierstiftung hat den Igel genauer
gesagt den
braunbrusigel zum Tier des Jahres 2024
gekürt bei der Abstimmung konnte sich
das Stacheltier klar gegen das
Eichhörnchen und den Rotfuchs
durchsetzen der Igel hierzulande ist
gefährdet es gibt immer weniger Nahrung
und geeignete
Unterschlüpfe für ihn braunbrustegel
sehr schön auf Straßen und gewwegen da
bleibt's gefährlich glatt wo genau das
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja horneffer
um
21:45 Uhr können Sie das heute journal
mit Marietta Slomka sehen uns morgen
wieder um 19 Uhr vielen Dank fürs
Einschalten entspannten Abend für
[Musik]
Sie
guten Abend nach dem winterlichen ersten
Adventswochenende fiel auch heute Schnee
für Sie hier rosa eingefärbt zunächst in
Norddeutschland dann aber kamen hier aus
dem Südwesten neue Schnee und Regenfälle
für sie blau eingefärbt heran und da war
zum Teil auch gefährlicher Glatteisregen
dabei es kommt nämlich ein neues Tief
heran und wenn das Regen mitbildt und
dieser Regen auf den gefrorenen Boden
fällt dann wird es spiegelglatt machen
Sie sich also bitte darauf gefasst in
Teilen von Nordrheinwestfalen reheinland
Hessen Thüringen badenwürtemberg und
Bayern in Norddeutschland kommt aus den
Wolken Schnee heraus das können
innerhalb von 12 Stunden durchaus auch 5
cm werden die Temperaturen über den
Schneeflächen in Süddeutschland sinken
bis -8° von Westen wird's milder da
steigen die Werte in der Nacht sogar
eher an 4° sind es dann an der Saar und
morgen zieht dieses kleine tief weiter
nordwärts vertreibt die Schneewolken in
Richtung Ostsee dann kommen neue Schnee
und Regenfälle im Südwesten auf dabei
fällt der Schnee wohl oberhalb von 400
bis 6 100 m es gibt allerdings auch ganz
freundliches Wetter hier zwischen dem
Thüringerwald dem Odenwald und der Donau
und die Temperaturen steigen morgen auf
-2° im nördlichen Brandenburg bis 7° am
Oberrhein und winterlich geht's auch
erstmal weiter guten
Abend